today we're testing to see what's the
difference between a 40 125 and a 500
racket we've got five challenges let's
see which paddle wins and if you watch
Until the End you'll find out exactly
what is the most suitable racket for
you've got two zero rack at first
oh the smash racket that leaves the
Sensei Sensei rackets now we will see
which rocket will complete the nightmare
trick shot
family you're supposed to serve I think
so too you have to do like a really
quickly
hey
[Applause]
this one's mine this challenge I'm gonna
get
[Music]
whoa the smash rocket it's the win oh I
I don't think the racket was too much of
a difference in this trick but smash
rocket took the win so next up we have
velocity returning a serve with each
racket you better work racket
[Applause]
[Music]
you have to have like crazy reactions
even touch the ball
you touched it
slightly closer
oh he got it
there we go okay
one out of one
come on
so one is that also makes a lot of sense
because the smash and the Sensei they're
slower they have less spin which means
it's easier to return fast and spinny
shots next challenge three games to
three points each one with a different
racket so we have samly who will be the
opponent of the day
plays with his own rackets but will the
racket make a difference
heavy under spin serve with a smash
that's a good example of how much spin
you can put with the smash racket
[Applause]
really
not bad
let's see how far we can hit the ball so
that it still comes back to my feet the
first one will be Smasher
oh
yeah that's that's coming back seven
meters and 80 centimeters that's
surprisingly good score Tennessee
records what
okay
that is it that is it that's two over
ten is it gonna come back
10.1 so it was like eight meters nine
meters and 10 meters the next stop is
the full Infinity sensei
okay yeah
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
set point
oh
beautiful
someone takes the game against the
Sensei racket so guess which racket is
this by the scent okay is it under my
nose yes
um Sensei rocket smells like sensei's
armpits
let's recognize this
is
I say the 500 records okay
which rackets
[Laughter]
[Music]
I would say you like the smell is so
good that it can't be the thing
this is the deciding set so now we play
for the victory
exactly
two meters over here that's the
difference in how fast the shorts go
[Applause]
oh
nice okay now let's see if it can deal
with the delicate deciding points
[Music]
so
[Applause]
set this up this was actually how the
sets went you could think that it's a
little regular but it's not really next
challenge making a heavy spin shot one
shot with each rocket let's see how
lossy returns them
[Music]
[Applause]
like it's going nowhere let's try it
with a Sensei next
still quite a lot of spin
oh I've got it on with the Sensei it's
returnable finally with the smash racket
ah got it so that's the thing you can't
generate as heavy spins with the lower
quality rackets the 500 one takes the
victory so from these three rackets
which one is the perfect for you let's
start with a smash rocket if you like to
play for fun and maybe get into the
sport more seriously without spending
too much money the smash racket is a
great choice as you can see the spins
and shots you can do with it are easily
enough to reach a solid level in table
tennis and it provides great control for
learning all the basic Strokes next up
the Sensei racket it's also a great
choice for a first Racket and it not
only suits beginners but also
intermediates the slightly thicker
surface Rubber and the largest sweet
spot on the blade allows you to step up
your game and play harder and spinnier
shots with more quality it's more
expensive but if you are thinking of
seriously leveling up in table tennis
the Sensei racket is for you lastly the
500 rackets as you saw the blade and
rubbers came separately and all
professional players use a customized
setup for playing but not all
customizable rackets are this fast and
expensive if you have reached a level in
your game where you know what
characteristics suit your style and what
speed and hardness you're looking for a
professional setup can be good to look
into but if you're not a pro yet the
safer option is to go with a ready-made
racket that you can find from pongfinity
dot store